welcome back and I've made this balance
sheet so messy I think it it would make
sense to to redraw it cleaned up a
little bit so what's our new bed after
we've unloaded a lot of those assets let
me assets so now the book value all I
have now I have a little bit of cash let
me write that down I had one dollar one
billion dollars of cash let's say
everything is in well write the bead
there so you know 1 billion of cash and
just you know you know Bank needs cash
to operate it can't just use all of its
cash to pay off things because they
don't won't be able even transact with
its customers or pay its rent or you
know send its executives on their
Learjets whatever it needs to do but
anyway you have 1 billion of cash so you
might have been thinking well why didn't
just use its cash to unload some of that
debt well you always have to keep some
cash online just to conduct business and
actually that's called working capital
but anyway back to the point of this
video so you have 1 billion dollars in
cash and at least the management of this
company thinks that it has 4 billion
dollars worth of residential CDOs and
this is the toxic stuff that's the focus
of of this government bailout which is
really historic in its proportions and
I'll talk more about that later and then
on the liability side so liabilities
liabilities what was left I think I had
called it loans see I'll write
liabilities in red just because they're
bad they're not bad but you know there's
something you oh so they're not as
pleasant so alone see and we said loan C
was three billion dollars three billion
and then what is the equity I'll do that
in yellow equity so the total assets
were five billion in assets right five
billion in assets total assets you have
three billion in liabilities so if you
believe what the what what the
accountants or the bank management has
said about their assets if you wanted to
just liquidate everything if you had
five billion assets you paid out you
liquidate them got five billion dollars
you paid off your three billion in loan
you'd be left with two billion dollars
so that's the equity two billion dollars
of equity
and just as a reminder how many shares
were there I think I originally said in
the original video that we have 500
million shares 500 million shares so
each of those shares is one 500
millionth of this equity so let's see
the book value per share let me write
that here book value per share is what
it's going to be the book value 2
billion divided by 500 million so it's
$4 $4 remember was $6 not too long ago
but we had to take that with those
commercial mortgages that we thought
were worth 10 billion actually ended up
being worth 9 billion so we lost a
billion dollars of our book value and a
billion dollars translates to $2 of the
share price anyway fair enough and you
know maybe at this point maybe at this
point the market value of the share
let's say the market value market value
so that's essentially the stock price if
you were to look up this company sticker
price let's say it's at $1 right because
they're like boy you know after all this
Bear Stearns and Lehman Brothers this is
all getting a little nerve-racking so
and and they have this the shady thing
over here so we have to be careful so if
the market value is $1 what are they
saying about the assets or what are they
saying about the equity well there that
was the market cap is the it's the share
price times the number of shares so that
they're saying essentially that the
market cap and that's equivalent to the
market value of the equity or what the
market thinks the equity is worth that's
$1 times 500 million shares so that's
worth 500 million 500 million or 0.5
billion so the market is actually saying
no you don't have two billion of equity
you only have half a billion of equity
and it's probably because they think
this is worth a billion and a half left
but anyway we'll leave that aside for
now but now we're getting to the crux of
the issue the two of those other loans
they came due no one was willing to
renew the loans or give them new loans
so the company had to liquidate some of
their assets in order to pay those loans
now now we're we're kind of this is the
endgame we have loan C and let's say
loan C comes due so they
say hey you know what things are really
shady I don't your your assets they look
very similar to Lehman Brothers and Bear
Stearns we're not going to renew your
loan you go out to the credit markets
you try to issue bonds you try to do
anything you can no one's willing to
give you a loan just because they're all
a little bit scared so what do you do
well you have to pay three billion
dollars of loans you just you just have
to write because no one's willing to
give you three billion dollars well you
say out of this cash I can't use all of
it if I just wanted to operate
bare-bones you know maybe I could give
point five billion cash but that's not
going to help my situation at all right
because that I still would have two and
a half billion left so you're like wow
I'm in a situation where I have to sell
these CDO so now now all my models and
all my assumptions are going to see if
they were even vaguely accurate right if
these things are worth really worth four
billion dollars so I go out there and I
try to sell my my CDOs I try to sell
them for for whatever I can get for them
because I have to sell them and one
there's no market for them because just
there's a lot of people who want to
unload them but there's not really
anybody who's keen on buying it so there
might not even be any market but you're
like no I want to sell them so you just
you know you broadcast it out to every
hedge fund and private equity fund and
every bank out and you say who wants to
buy my CDOs and some private equity firm
comes to you okay well you know I think
that those things are pretty toxic but
they're probably worth maybe something
I'm pretty optimistic about the real
estate market and maybe in ten years
they might come back so I'm willing to
give you I'm willing to give you one
billion dollars for that those CDOs
right so essentially you know what's the
market price of something it's the best
price that someone's willing to give you
for something so the market price of
this because you shopped it around
you've gone to the market you've gone to
everyone you can the market price for
this is essentially the market is
offering you 1 billion dollars for this
CDO so what do you do well if you sell
it for 1 billion dollars does that help
your situation if you sell this for 1
billion dollars you get a billion
dollars here you have a billion dollars
of cash you have a total of two billion
dollars that still won't pay
you're still going to be bankrupt and
even more the company management they're
very stubborn they say you know what one
if I sell it I'm gonna go bankrupt and I
think that that's some kind of fire sale
price quote unquote that that's not the
real price all of a sudden for the first
time in my career when I was getting you
know when I was getting thirty million
dollar bonuses I heavily believed in the
market but now I'm in denial of the
market I say you know what the only
reason why there you know I'm only
getting a billion dollars for this is
because everyone is afraid and these
things if someone were to just hold them
to maturity if someone were to just hold
these assets for the thirty years over
which you know their mortgages the
underlying mortgages will just you know
pay out someone's going to collect
roughly four billion or maybe at worst
three-and-a-half billion so I'm not
gonna I'm not going to do this but
really you have no choice so what you
try to do is you say well can someone
give me some type of a loan can someone
type it you know just just lend me some
money in the short term just so that I
could get this paid off and I'll be
willing to give this as collateral right
collateral on the loan is you give me a
loan and you take this as collateral and
if I don't pay the loan you just keep
the asset right and that's essentially
what the Fed was doing the Fed
traditionally only gives loans if you
give something really nice as a
collateral like you know Treasuries or
essentially just Treasuries and and
they'll still take a little discount of
your collateral like if you give if you
give the Federal Reserve a dollar of
Treasuries they might give you 80 cents
of loans but over this whole credit
crunch the Fed has gotten looser and
looser in terms of what it's willing to
accept as collateral so actually the Fed
I don't I don't know the details of how
toxic of an asset they were willing to
take his collateral but they were will
they started loosening it up to pretty
pretty toxic assets so maybe you could
get a loan but let's just put that aside
right now but this is the situation
we're facing you have a bank and it's
essentially being forced or it perceives
it forced into bankruptcy even though
even though it thinks that it has
positive equity so you could get a loan
from the Fed or someone else if they're
willing to take this kind of toxic stuff
as collateral let's assume that they're
not for now the other option is you can
recapitalize you can get someone to
invest in
firm you can sell equity in the firm and
get some more cash to pay off this loan
if you can convince someone that no your
firm is really in the future going to be
worth a lot more this is just a
stressful situation so you go to some
sovereign wealth fund and that's just a
way of saying a some foreign government
that's been collecting dollars because
they've been selling this oil or cheap
manufactured goods so you go to those
that look you know we are this super Bri
nowhere where Goldman Brothers or you
know where Lehman Sachs we are this this
great brand in the banking industry
wouldn't you like to have a piece of
this thing that represents American
capitalism and they say sure you know
you know we'll be interested in
investing so they they say well you know
what the market price is a dollar and
you know III think you're that's
probably a little distressed so we'll be
willing to pay a dollar fifty per share
and we'll buy I don't know we'll buy
let's see how much do you need we'll buy
two billion shares at a dollar fifty per
share so what happens so let's say the
sovereign wealth fund sovereign wealth
fund they're going to buy two billion
shares two billion shares at a dollar
fifty per share so now what does the
balance sheet look like so two billion a
dollar fifty per share they're
essentially giving you that that is
equal to three billion dollars right so
now you get three billion more in cash
so this becomes four billion but you
can't get something for free so what
where is what what happened are our
liabilities increasing well no our
liabilities increase they didn't give us
a loan right they they invested in this
they essentially bought shares of the
company they bought two billion shares
so how does that get accounted for well
instead of our share count being five
hundred million shares this is how many
shares before we had before the company
essentially created two billion new
shares so now the company has 2.5
billion shares so now we have 2.5
billion shares and it's something
interesting here what is the new book
value of the shares so what are our
total assets for Billy
plus four billion it's 8 billion of
assets our liabilities are still 3
billion now our the value of our share
after the investment and you can kind of
call this the post value the post-money
valuation or Book value is 5 billion
right 8 billion minus 3 billion and now
what's the Book value of our shares see
five billion divided by five hundred and
I'm sorry but / 2.5 billion it's two
dollars per share it's two dollars per
share so our new Book value is two
dollars per share and that's interesting
because it's someplace in two dollars
per share this is two dollars per share
someplace in between our old book value
and the price that the company paid
right they are the sovereign wealth fund
paid a dollar fifty per share but anyway
I just wanted I just realize I'm out of
town time again I'll continue this in
the next video